[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: OS Login is a
Compute Engine service
that provides an easy way
to manage user permissions
for accessing instances via SSH
using Compute Engine IAM roles.
However, having multiple roles
on different resource levels
can make it confusing to
figure out access issues.
Let's take a look at how
to investigate SSH access
issues with OS Login and the
IAM policy troubleshooter.
First, let's review a few
different roles for users
to use OS Login.
Compute.osAdminLogin
allows the user
to SSH into the instance
as an administrator,
while compute.osLogin
allows them
to SSH in as a regular user.
The iam.serviceAccountUser
role allows a user
to run operations as
a service account.
These roles can be granted
at the project level
so they can apply to
resources inside that project.
They can also be granted
at a more granular level,
such as an instance or a
service account directly.
Let's walk through an example.
We'll start by trying
to SSH into myinstance-1
On Instances Details page, we
can see the service account
for this instance.
At the top of the
page, the SSH button
will let us connect to the
instance, so let's go ahead
and click it.
Looks like everything
is working well.
Now, let's try the same
thing with myinstance-2.
We'll head over to the
Instance Details page
from the main menu.
This instance is also running
the same service account,
but when we scroll up to the
SSH option, it's greyed out.
That's strange.
Let's try it from
the command line
instead by using the
Cloud Shell terminal
and running gcloud compute SSH.
We get a permission denied
error, which explains why
the SSH button was greyed out.
But without any other
details, how can we figure out
why we don't have permission?
Let's evaluate the
permissions required
in the policy troubleshooter.
We can evaluate
multiple permissions
on multiple resources
at the same time
so that we can compare
the results of each.
Let's check for the
compute.instances.osLogin
permission on myinstance-1
and myinstance-2.
This permission
comes from the roles
that we mentioned earlier.
We'll add our user
as the principal
and add the full resource
name and permission.
Also, since these instances are
running as a service account,
we can check for the
iam.serviceAccounts.actas
permission on the
actual service account.
The permission is part of the
service account user role.
The policy
troubleshooter shows us
details on the
permissions for our users.
We can change between our views
by using the dropdown here.
The first view shows
us that OS Login
is granted to myinstance-1, and
we can see the specific details
here on the right.
When we switch the view
over to myinstance-2,
we can see that our user doesn't
have the same permissions.
Since the user doesn't
have the right permissions,
they can't connect through SSH.
Let's add our user by going
to the Compute Engine page.
From here, we can
select the instance
and grant our user the
compute.osLogin role.
Now that we can see the
user has the role, let's
try connecting
through SSH again.
Once that's done, we can so that
the user is now able to SSH in.
Another option would be to
grant the user compute.osLogin
at the project
level, which would
allow them to use OS Login for
all instances in the project.
Keep in mind the security best
practice of least privilege,
and set your
permissions accordingly.
Take a look at the
documentation to read more
about policy troubleshooter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]